what's up everyone welcome to simulation
Rory and I are going to be talking about
unmet needs so important it's so crucial
we have spent the last couple days so as
I've come back from doing those
interviews in China just identifying
aspects of my being that can use
improvement and he's been calling me out
and one of them was the unmet needs we
want to get specific with my unmet needs
and give this as like an example should
we start with like more high levels
fired you to shoot an episode on unmet
needs
[Applause]
a subject that is so important as we
mentioned at the beginning yet gets so
little coverage out of all of the
content that exists and so to be able to
just talk about something that may be
viewed as taboo or I can't show my
vulnerability by talking about my unmet
needs that's why we don't talk about
them on the internet or even really in
person mm-hmm so to me fields like that
where it's really clear that people are
not talking about them to me there's
usually something interesting about why
usually but it but it also has something
to do with just in general the Ascension
process you know you don't want to talk
about something that is like in the
older part of the Overton Window meaning
like you don't want to talk about how
owning slaves is okay because that was
okay over old thousands of years ago and
now it's like dude nobody should own
slaves and so like even though no one's
talking about that we don't want to talk
about that but no one's talking about
unmet needs but so this is like more on
the other side of the Overton Window
where it's like there's not that many
people talking about it but not because
it's like old ethics this is like new
ethics that not enough people are
talking about so that's why we should
talk about it Wow
that's a lot
um
and just let's quickly fix this so that
it uh yeah
so it's pointed upwards
that's better there we are
yeah it's a great topic I think that
unmet needs could be a key focal point
to take the keep of focal point to
purifying ourselves and becoming better
vessels to
Jen's world
mmm okay so purification was the word
they used
you've been using that word a lot what
does purification mean
um purification means
[Music]
purifying our
what does it mean to you the classic we
get this one on the show occasionally we
ask a question and the guest is like
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing huh they just shoot the question
back
it has something to do with Karma
I love that
that is my say we are team
like
I'm distorting our essential will mmm
mmm that's good yeah that's add that's
where I'm about to take it to so as you
manifest your ultimate destiny admission
purpose into the world purification is
the process of removing bad intent and
bad actions and increasing good intent
and what is it bad intent that's a yeah
yeah that's how hard question what is a
good versus bad yeah to me it's
unconscious intent
just that unconscious intent is bad it's
pretty good
[Music]
like
when we we talked we're talking about
needs when we meet our needs we can
become more conscious to more of our
needs we can become more aware of our
greater needs and our more expanded
needs and our more trans personal needs
our bigger cell
cuts off with a capital S that sells
needs you know and but it starts with
meeting the small self needs and having
this healthy healing and integration
process of our parts so
yeah
okay so so it could be that we have a
process of
purification that could be said is to
clear away bad intent bad actions bring
forth good intent and good actions and
as you described it conscious intent and
conscious actions
because then once one's actions and
intent to become conscious they are more
aware of karma and therefore choose good
rather than bad because they know that
it has an effect a cause and effect a
butterfly effect on their lineage and on
the people around them and on their
prior and forward yeah so then you talk
about this self that has the small self
maybe that can be thought of as in this
body right and then there's this big
self this higher self big-ass self and
that can be thought of maybe as your
eternal spirit
yeah and the proper the collective or
the collective yeah and so the process
of meeting unmet needs and purifying
starts with the little s self here in
this body okay so then what are the most
common unmet needs
that's a great question
there's a bunch one of the most common
unmet needs
common unmet needs I think the essential
one the essential when you know you
could list an emotional needs like need
for touch they need to be held they need
to hold another they need to do this but
if we go really essential about it I
think it has to do with witnessing
consciousness itself seeing itself and
so in that sense one can meet all their
needs alone not saying they have to but
if you give it's all about the
effectiveness of the witnessing so you
may have sexual needs you may have like
the other ones I listed social order
like all kinds of needs but if you get
really good at witnessing them at and
there's many ways to do that but
basically your consciousness shining its
light on this need hmm accurately
accurate witnessing then they tend to
dissolve they tend to heal it and to
integrate and it's healthy hmm and
that's purification ooh interesting okay
so there's a myriad of unmet needs that
are pretty classic for people I believe
there's still upwards of a billion
people on the planet that don't have
access to clean water on a frequent
basis so that's still an unmet need that
one is very primordial very basics and
there's like the developing world needs
and like the developing world needs
typically land in the categories you
were listing about like love touch of
being held touching others etc like yeah
yeah yeah okay and then there's probably
a ridiculous amount more of the most
that needs but you said that the most
efficacious process of purification is
putting the cautious spotlight on the
unmet needs yeah
so let's give an example so
let's instead of talking abstractly
let's go right into me okay yeah okay I
think that helps people a lot and it
will help me and yeah okay so we live in
the developing world so we have shelter
air food water electricity education
healthcare basic stuff transit
but a lot of people in developing world
still need of the basic need met of
greater financial security so that they
don't become financially ruined with an
even a tiny bill they can't pay their
rent some stuff like that it feels like
our project is finally slowly after two
years making its way out of that like
yeah like a five hundred dollar bill
wouldn't make it so that we want to be
able to pay our rent which it like feels
incredible mm-hmm okay so now that's met
and so now it feels like almost like
this next bit of escalating unmet need
that's within me probably has to do with
how there's a couple right now that
we've been talking about quite a bit
like one of them is this longing for a
twin flame of sorts mm and that's kind
of like what it's been like now like
more popularly called which I like that
a lot more I think it's a lot more
accurate like this isn't some like swipe
right and and have one-night stand and
then you know that's like more
unconscious behavior more cautious
behavior is more like I want to identify
someone that I don't even care if it's
for a month three months six months 12
months it's that they're kind of you're
like we went away from what we were
about to do which with what to look at
your needs ok whyme slowly listing one
at least which is this need for like a
twin flame okay so why why don't we stay
there yeah okay I was just
intellectualizing about all it doesn't
matter the lightbulb oh right right
right
the intellectualizing is one part of
seeing yes but we also have our gut in
our heart heart yeah and when I dip into
my heart when I think about the emotion
around like a twin flame I melt mmm
interesting yeah
so this is so neither are
you melt yeah
I feel
that is cool Sony's have a lot of
richness under them yes yeah yes and you
can really transform how we feel and hmm
they're so real they're so juicy they're
so
worthy of
being worked with
yes they are
[Music]
you have a melting and ascending is
another one that's part of that whole to
enflame process yeah I'm kind of melt
yeah because one of the things about
this is now I think becoming more more
people are putting the spotlight on this
especially like really well studied
philosophers and I think it's very
fascinating it's the phenomenon of when
you're in that moment with a twin flame
with that everything outside of the
moment yeah ceases to exist
you know it's interesting if I can share
yeah
open
when you share that
I have a hard time sharing your joy
big perhaps because of my unmet need
maybe we talk about that a little bit
yeah okay
I have a need for
and maybe this won't be on the list of
needs in a book but the thing that comes
up is like the phrase rightful place
and
it feels like that need gets under
threat when you share about your need
hmm
the interesting
now I probably have some explaining to
do about what I mean when I say rightful
place mm-hmm
if I feel into it it's like
just wanting my self to be undistorted
my expression in the world
or in community or in relationship or on
video to be undistorted my choice of who
I am my choice of how to be to to be
undistorted and so for that to land in
the world in relationship of it in its
rightful place
and
so something about your sharing feels
threatening to that need
and I see your eyes and your energy
field still kind of in this melting as
you put it state and that's beautiful
and normally now that normally I would
share that yeah would that you're
melting is my lovely yeah but in this
particular case I feel
I feel like
I don't feel not that
I feel
like vigilant and I feel
like I'm scanning and I feel
very alert about
my social perception and perhaps the one
that I want to
have
when you're first talking about your
place
in rightful place
[Music]
that is this beautiful journey that
happens as you would ventured into this
consciousness for you to be this little
s self right now and try and reconnect
with this big-ass
self on what did I come here to do what
is my purpose what is my mission that
it's and this might be more about how I
viewed that you view myself and view
other people it might not be right with
you with what you're experiencing but
that so much of the time it's important
to set our
[Music]
our love for the journey for the process
of becoming along the way moment by
moment into the rightful place and each
moment is a rightful place and like the
verses look a lot of the time it looks
like is that we say okay by this certain
age I'm gonna have this certain thing
and then that's gonna be my rightful
place and I just I'm like like it makes
sense to have these maybe little like
milestones of like well we want to have
a certain amount of shows done by a
certain time or that we want to go visit
a certain country to do partnership
shows by a certain time like have goals
but also just know that I'm not missing
my rightful place by missing one of
those goals maybe so that it's may be
constantly process of interest
also we're in different parts in our
life trajectories albeit were the same
age we're in different parts of our life
trajectories in the sense that like we
maybe both have picked up our like what
we're passionate about around like the
same ish ish time mm-hmm
holding space interviewing but the Karma
behind those endeavors is different yeah
it's like if you were just about
conscious evolution and you're just in
your bed all day every day meeting your
needs healing growing working with
coaches whatever then you would be
perhaps less connected to the web the
networks that you're here to connect
with yeah
and so you have this openness this
interest this readiness for healing and
growth but also in the back of your mind
you're sensitive to the timing of things
and the connections you have does that
resonate yeah that resonates yeah yeah
it resonates and also it may be that
part of the reason why my unmet need of
having like a twin flame to endeavor
with on the mission for however long it
may be may be one of the reasons why
that unmet need and your unmet need of
being in the rightful place may feel a
little bit of conflict is that there may
be a process of me meeting my twin flame
unmet need and then maybe focusing less
on the unmet needs of our project that
we're working on and our projects unmet
needs directly catalyze your rightful
place as a space holder on larger and
larger stages yeah and so that seems to
me to make a lot of sense but also with
this whole twin flame thing I think it's
really important to put it into the
perspective that it's possible that you
and a you and a twin flame could have a
very serious ascension process where
you're both constantly working on each
other in really beautiful nuance where
it actually could benefit my project it
could benefit her project that type of
thing like a lot but it could also be a
distractor for both her and I in that
sense so it's again it's kind of like
who is this person if it was truly a
twin flame went to be one that was
a massive catalyst to that both
endeavors and so
that's one okay one moment with this
unmet need like yeah one of the unmet
needs was this like to enflame thing and
you know one of the aspects was that
melting and the other aspect was that
ascending so these like beautiful
harmony of that but also another unmet
need that i think is like
that we should talk about is like we
have now accumulated enough ideas and
enough especially ideas around content
distribution and ideas around how to
awaken other people and inspire other
people around the world through content
distribution that there's like a very
small unmet need right now
maybe it's actually massive unmet need
with having that bit more of financing
to bring on a rockstar full time video
editor to help us with the distribution
and of these synthesis and dissemination
of them yeah yes that's another one that
came up yeah the need for the financial
abundance to hire the
teammates we need like a video editor
you say
yeah you know the other day we were
going into this and we uncovered a deep
knee a deeper need hmm
yes let's unpacked what was it which was
maybe the need for having enough a very
basic need mm-hmm I mean that's a vibe I
get when we bring this up yeah
like how does it feel emotionally when
you really let yourself feel into your
body about this desire for a text video
editor and more financial abundance for
the project hmm okay and your body
emotionally
like both that
that I've had this feeling of this uh of
this like on this unmet like basic
support that could help the show grow
faster since like two years ago but that
now two years later we're at a much more
significant milestone where it makes it
more like okay come on like we've done
something at least so it should be
easier which we just talked about a
little bit ago like a five hundred
dollar bill isn't gonna make it so we
can't pay rent next month but this
should be easier for us to send this
really cool deck that we've made to the
different VCS and philanthropists and
literally the people that we interview
on our show and for them to feel like
that they want to contribute to
sponsoring some episodes or that they
want to advertise on the platform or
that they want to link us up with the
people that may want to invest in what
we're doing
10k hundred K a million bucks can help
move things along with what we're doing
quite a bit at the smallest levels with
a little bit of video editing and the
medium levels maybe a video production
team and starting the TV series and in
the bigger stages we can do movies we
can do books we can do multimedia
content we can build a full fledged
recording studio in a beautiful house
and travel to different places and
procure guests of different calibers
from around the world yes and it makes
it so that we don't have to in this
sense now we have a next worry and
aren't worried isn't a $500
sudden bill but our next worry is maybe
something along the lines of like well
instead of having like like 2,000 bucks
of like monthly reoccurring revenues if
we have 4000 bucks of monthly recurring
revenues we won't have to worry about
this potential we have an empty room
right now and this house could go on the
market for
secondly more money than what we're
currently incubating it for and so
that's also something that we have to be
very aware of like with that little bit
more money we could come up with the
funding to take the whole hold and yeah
and so like that's where we see this
envision we our vision is that filling
the extra bedroom right now with a
high-caliber Video Editor and be able to
take the whole home with this recording
studio in the living room and and take
off with the vision for at least the
next nine months here and so now we have
to deal with you know and what's what's
two more grand a month to billionaires
it's nothing we just interviewed one
earlier today like right so
this is another unmet need is this
feeling of greater creative expression
and potential and ascension and growth
with the slightly bit more financial
resources that enable us to go to the
next level yeah yeah yeah
thank you for sharing
like that base of me feels like it's
pretty much there for a lot of a lot of
people that basic unmet need seems like
it's there for a lot of people if only I
had that extra you know for certain
developing parts of the world it's like
10 or 20 or a hundred bucks yeah we help
them take have their business take off
right for needs are a double sided coin
you know it's he sided 20
beyond the sides of the coin the NIMH
itself and meeting it and the love the
love the love making experience of
meeting the need a lot of are you called
it a lovemaking experience cuz that's
what it is it is once you hit that
milestone of like okay a $500 bill isn't
gonna ruin us it's like that's a
lovemaking feeling
that also in a sense is kind of what you
were referencing I thought with this
rightful place like if it's a lovemaking
experience every moment of ascending
into the rifle place yeah
yeah
that's interesting but just now when you
share it a five hundred dollar bill
isn't gonna ruin us yeah
again I had a hard time sharing you're
melting beautiful state you know why do
you think that is well
because is an element of unconsciousness
with that bliss
let's talk about that element of
unconsciousness how do you see it
there's an element you're leaving the
$500 bill and you're dreaming up that
it's not you know you're leaving the
$500 but you're not you're not touching
the $500 bill in making that statement
what does that mean like if I was you
know my reason why you're leaving it the
reason why your perception isn't
perfectly clear yeah yeah is because
these needs hold a weight they oh yeah
they okay
we can't stay touching a five dollar
bill when needs are so real in us you
know and so so what does this mean
like I bet a good amount of people are
actually experiencing something like
this where they're trying to like move
to the next level in a sense how would
you foresee a conscious connection to
that on what once was an unmet need of
being able to fill a $500 bill if one
came up
how would you consciously move from that
unmet need maybe integrate it embody and
move on to the next level how would you
do that process
can you guess it again more concisely so
maybe like like level five is being able
to fulfill a five hundred dollar bill
without issue and level four is having
serious issue if a 500 dollar bill comes
up how do you make them move from level
4 to level five in a conscious way
because you told me that I was treating
a little unconsciously so yeah
aka how do you skillfully integrate like
unmet need yeah yeah yeah you you and
you actually taught us about that put
the spotlight on it right yeah so I'm
not consciously enough putting the
spotlight on the five hundred dollar
bill yeah okay so how would you
consciously put the spotlight would it
be like you know you have done a lot of
practice with journaling a lot of
practice with grief so would for me then
would it be like that as well or how
could I practice consciously putting the
spotlight on the founder dog bill maybe
Lou reflecting back to the experiences
where $500 bills really did stress me
out a lot yeah these are good
these are good how does your need behind
the question been met my need behind the
question by you validating how I felt
about maybe it's journaling or griefing
or or reflecting on those experiences
when it did cause a lot of stress that I
was wrong bill I like that that that
seems like it would be helpful yeah
sweet sweet yeah
okay but then you also okay so okay so
let's let's let's list these things okay
so if you Journal or grief or or reflect
on the periods of time when five hundred
I built it's dressy that's one of these
unmet needs and how to put the spotlight
on it and ascend more integrated ly and
then there's let's say this other unmet
need which is this you know this just
like to enflame one let's say like how
would you recommend me or other people
to do something like dive into their
unmet need yeah yeah okay yeah well I'll
just pause you because as you're sharing
all this conceptual content yeah I'm
feeling like
like I'm feeling like a weighty dense
matter in the room
that we begun to Poquette if you will
and it's still here haha it's like a
dead animal and and like it's just like
sitting on us and like it's here for a
reason and it's probably
maybe it's this I'm gonna I'm gonna go
ahead and share
I had a very unconscious lapse in my
unmet need of
twin flame sexual proclivity I had a
very unconscious lapse I'm wondering if
that's what it is
mmm yeah and it's like what was present
causing you to lose touch with yes what
was the deeper denser matter yeah that
you were working around to function
what is this deep dense matter I
actually had another minor unconscious
lapse today I mean it just it just keeps
happening honestly that's the thing yeah
so this is beautiful because oh my
there's all this stuff I want to share
around it which is um but but I wonder
if I should right now
because
yeah back to the matter at matter at
hand okay you can choose whenever you
want to pull that up interrupt me in if
you want to share there's um okay
there's these this there's this like
major unconscious lapse in sexual
proclivity that wasn't even associated
really deeply with the twin flame like
the twin flame is some like really like
ideal spiritual ascension with another
being that is also a deeply romantically
intertwined okay and then there's
literally like the opposite of that
which is like
the deep primordial urges of monkeys -
[ __ ] yeah I like I like how you describe
it with deep in primordial
and like for me it's really hard to
consciously ascend past the deep
primordial monkey urge to [ __ ] yeah it's
like it's like a humanist or even an
animal miss yes
and it prevents you from transcending
both whoo yeah on a full embodied level
yeah yeah you want to know what the
other one is yeah just quickly the other
one I think that's such a human and
animal istic tendency that is very
difficult to escape to a higher state of
consciousness as being the other one I
think for me at least is food food is
the other one for me
mm-hmm yes I can fast for a day yes I
fasted for three days once a month ish
and that feels great
philosophize bus yes the monkey still
here wanting you to express this other
thing
well I'm give me I'm getting there these
are enix these are these are totally and
extra tably linked yeah I must explain
this one as well okay and there's a
third example here that I think is
actually also linked to the other two
but that I have actually done a good
amount of self work on okay so the I'm
serious so this could be pretty good so
there's this unmet here's okay here's an
unmet need of sexual proclivity and at
the highest point like deep sigh I think
I think deeper and sexual proclivity
it's it's actually just emotional it's
yeah it's a malnourished mint you know
you talked about food yeah it all comes
down to like food or emotion or like
just life energy hmm so it's like a
malnourished no interesting and with
proper witnessing interesting okay okay
maybe you should continue on that for a
bit okay
because that's what I think it feels
like for a lot of people this mouth
nourishment like why do we look at
someone on the street in a way that is
deeply primordial there's some sort of
put up probably malnourished but that's
occurring that is like if there was just
a little bit more nourishment with that
emotion like you were describing that
maybe that that would the feeling would
come off the mound nourishment prevents
us from touching the infinite
nourishment that God has for us the
unconditional love that's here
that's why meeting needs is important
because yeah knees take us away from the
unconditional love that is so back to
the specific example at hand
what's it like to be with and this is so
people may not realize this is so like
you know you could call this like our
root chakra is the lower chakra it's
like close to like your survival and so
it grips you it grips your being yeah
it's not that easy to override your yes
this and so now we're here with it
we're being present too
something real you know people call it
an inner child there's a million ways to
look at these things but there's
something here and it's real
and
it's dense
it's human or animal
and it impacts your expression totally
it impacts your embodiment of your soul
or higher self this and so now we're
with it we're curious about it what's
your relationship with this thing mmm
this is good that actually leads into
that exact point that I was getting to a
couple minutes ago you mentioned this
really good point along the way that I
just have to talk about quick which is
that the unmet needs strip us away from
the unconditional love this godlike
unconditional love that permeates
everything then that's why it's so
important to meet needs I really like
that a lot
and then what is my relationship
- this density in this like root chakra
feeling it just gripping me one of them
is on the dis primordial sexual
proclivity and at this highest state can
be seen as like a twin flame ascension
the second one is food and in one aspect
it's eating literally as an escape
eating really unhealthy foods eating
them excessively frequently binge eating
it's a victimless you know I I the foods
of the face I think I think that
gluttony might be like there might be
some sort of like a victim there
although I get what you're saying was
like victim less I I still would like to
say like you had to slaughter animals if
you're like you know there is a victim
yeah like or or stripping plants of
their life so you can consume them for
the energy that they've taken from the
Sun so just on unclick just I want to
see if I can knock these three out the
second one has like this yeah gluttony
addiction to food and then on this
higher ascension of consciousness around
food could maybe be something around
like healthier eating habits that are
way more rare rare only when you need
nourishment and not like overly
excessive and needing nourishment is
arguable like you only need like a
handful of almonds and like a banana and
like a handful of spinach and you're
like pretty good for the day so like
there's some really serious stuff to
iron out with our habits of eating
excessive amounts of food three times a
day that are okay then the third one
right so I'm let's say I have
I have some issues with the first one
and some issues with the second one
still that I need to put my spotlight on
and work on that self work with those
two the third one
yeah the third one and this is the final
one for me at least I was literally just
thinking about this today this one I've
done better at and so this is a
different example I would say it's it's
in the same buckets but a lot of people
are choosing to endeavor into alcohol
endeavor into cannabis endeavor into all
different types of psychedelics
tobacco's just basically trip jumping
they got to jump from alcohol trip to
cannabis trip to mushroom trip to
smoking cigarettes to like to just jump
jump jump jump jump and it's the same
thing with food and sex as people jump
to those trips yeah but I'm and so with
the with this drug is one with the
mind-altering substances one that's the
one that I finally I think I have a
pretty good grip on that deep lower
chakra that's constantly trying to get
me to
I have that beer with everyone drink
that glass of wine with everyone yeah
smoke that joint your blunt with
everyone or take the LSD or the
mushrooms or whatever and I'm just like
no no no no no no no no no and I'm just
I'm feeling hella good about it I'm just
like yo the fact that I stayed this
sober on a daily basis is making my
intelligence just super deeply
compounded on what I'm learning everyday
and I'm not like messing around with my
brother dunking your vessel yeah I'm
sunk in your vest in a sense so I have
some gunk in your sink an ally because
when these needs arise and we're like
present to them instead of suppressing
them and like just brute forcing our
functioning then we become impaired you
know we realize like holy [ __ ] there's a
reason why I wasn't meeting the needs or
why I wasn't like witnessing them and
healing because they're so like real and
so they impaired like we become impaired
temporarily you know our brain function
gets slower and where it's like we're
drunk but then the after the before and
after the after is like you're saying
like this kind of our and our vessels
can become industrial-grade and we can
become our intelligence right people the
word intelligent our intelligence
becomes vaster our capacities and yes
yeah
let's get some water in this vessel oh
my gosh that's so good
damn so
like you you we've probably all felt
what ore is talking about where your
decision-making is literally clouded by
the unmet needs in the deepest part of
the chakra around food or around sex or
around drugs or around any of these
things and like you literally feel like
your mind is being clouded during that
process you're like kind of in a sense
you're like fighting you're trying to
ascend away from the most primordial
needs but like do it in a way like you
said that is highlighting and
spotlighting the different unmet needs
and integrating them as you ascend and
not just like [ __ ] pushing them down
and hoping they never volcano back up
because in a sense I've had that
experience several times where I'm just
like push push push push push push push
and then all of a sudden I'm like on a
streak of doing something around his sex
or something around food that is just
not conscious because I've just been
pushing the [ __ ] down yeah
yeah
when those are not fulfilled the unmet
needs we don't have as much of a
capacity to commune with God and with
the divine and with unconditional love
yeah
and here's what happens I can give you
examples for all these things with the
with the sex you're on the street and
you're just constantly drooling over the
men or the women that you see because
you have on men need their with food
instead of taking the food and literally
respecting how it's nourishing you while
you eat it and being great for it you're
just shoving things over and over again
into your mouth and the last one like
with drugs instead of being like okay
for this one ceremonial every six months
occasion I'm going to intake a very
small amount of a substance that is very
small that's just going to feel and
ceremony you'll see what happens
versus like literally going from trip -
trip to trip like multiple times per
week trying to ascend through through
trips over and over and over again like
there's like deeply beautiful ways
godlike ways to commune with sex food
drugs and so many these other basic
unmet need categories but in many ways
we're behaving I am on especially two of
them less consciously than I should be
and this is a beautiful lesson for me to
meet those needs more deeply and
then that will affect myself my
relationships my family my everything
with just a deeper more godlike feeling
some less unmet basic needs feeling
this has been really good back and forth
I liked it a lot
do you have more you want to share poori
Shapira
I think that
the next world
shall be one where
those who work with their and others
needs
this next iteration working with unmet
needs
[Music]
and therefore half this base
to
move
without extortion
they should have a say
I love my vision
more space for meeting unmet needs
love that
what do you think cool unwrapping hi
well that was a lot of fun everyone
thanks for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it thank you so much we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode on unmet
needs let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations your friends
families co-workers people online about
unmet needs let's just have that
question be asked more often around our
world what are some of your unmet needs
and just have conscious conversation
about that process so check out the
links in the bio below you know where to
support or you withholding space you
know where to support simulation so you
can continue building out this project
and also like we mention during the show
your support will help us get to those
next levels and it is literally as
simple as tiny little donations across
any of the platforms below you can find
our paypal patreon cryptocurrency link
all that cool stuffs below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon
peace